one of the things that i'm not able to
do is i'm not able to stay in one place
because
i'm italian and i have to use my hands
and i have to walk around so if it's
creeping anybody out i'll try not to
stay in one spot
too long um but i i think that
you know in the last few years i've
talked
towards the end uh like the end and
that's always hard because everybody
wants to go
now it's you know day one right after
lunch so i
we'll see um at least i'm not between
you and lunch
so um i'm also very cognizant of the
fact that now we're recording
the presentation which means i can't
completely misbehave
because they'll be recording of it but
you know fortunately we have the finest
admin available and it very good to
talk to you very good so so that's
that's good
um i'm going to talk today about
the journey that we're on at dmv in
terms of
not just data but the relationship of
data
and and how that's informing our
thinking so
you know at dmb is an interesting
company it's been around there's only 11
companies in the united states that have
been around as long as dmv and before
the financial crisis there was about 49.
so that's kind of scary we've been we
got started before the civil war
and that the basic premise of the
company is should i do business with
this guy
and if i do how much opportunity is
there so we call that total risk and
total opportunity
how hard could that be well that could
be really hard
it's arguably one of the largest
commercial databases on earth it's not
as big as
a lot of the databases that the people
in this room represent as databases go
but in terms of the dynamic nature of
business and how frequently things
change and then you think about
doing this in hundreds of company
countries in different languages and
different writing systems there's
different statutory environments there's
different
laws for permissible use um there's
there's a constantly
changing competitive landscape all of a
sudden you know flappy birds is
collecting data on companies and
you know and and there you go so it's a
very interesting
world that we live in interesting in the
chinese sense of the word that it could
be an opportunity or a curse we haven't
decided which yet
um but it's it's definitely something
where
there's an opportunity to make new
mistakes every day and and that's one of
my goals
is to try to make new mistakes every day
so
talk a little bit about three different
things the first is you know how hard
could this really be
um you know when you think about
businesses in terms of
you know collecting data as opposed to
exoplanets it seems like it might be a
little easier
to collect information on businesses but
we'll see
the second is uh anybody in the room
speak french
so keep me honest
interesting french expression the more
things change the more they're kind of
the same
everything old is new again right so
some else
no mercy but the problem here is that
things really aren't the same so things
that are the same
are different now they're used for
different reasons so
the same kind of information that we
used to throw away
because it was unuseful is now the gold
the same kind of information
that that we used to try very hard to go
get
is now freely available so very very
different world
while yet the same kind of problems just
in cast in a different way
and then finally i want to talk about
relationships and the connected nature
of data and how we view that and some of
the work that we're doing with the fine
folks from wolfram solutions so
i'm going to try and get all that done
in less than 30 minutes because
that's what they asked me to do so there
you go um first thing
is does anybody here speak greek
rats uh there's always somebody so this
says
the nothing no nothing safton if you
want to read it in like ancient greek
it means know yourself does anybody know
what this is
it's the inscription on at delphi when
you go to the temple at delphi
so one of the original predictive
analytical
analytic environments was actually the
temple of delphi
and you would basically go there with a
question
and just like any true analytical
environment you would get an answer that
you can interpret any way you want
so you would go and ask a question and
your question might be
you know will i be victorious in war and
the answer would be the true of heart
are victorious in war and you say well
i'm true apart and you go off and you
if you win then the oracle was right and
if you lost you were not true of heart
and the oracle was right so
um we do a lot of that
in the big data environment especially
when we talk about businesses so
the first thing i did was i looked at d
and b and i said well how do we talk
about ourselves
that ought to be pretty straightforward
right so here's
one you know this is from our corporate
website and it says dnb
and then down here this is on our
investor relations page contact us
the dun and bradstreet corporation right
is that the same company look at our
address down here 103
john f kennedy parkway short hills new
jersey if you look at my business card
it says 103 jfk parkway jfk parkway not
john f kennedy parkway
here's the problem uh pkwy on my
business card parkway here
not really the same thing park john f
kennedy
and jfk not really the same thing nj in
new jersey not really the same thing
actually short hills isn't even really a
city it's the hoity-toity part of a town
called milburn
so if you're in short hills at our
headquarters and you call the police the
millburn police show up
right so nothing's right the only thing
right on my business card is 103.
and that's a company that's involved in
curating identity of businesses and
that's how we talk about ourselves
without even trying hard that's how far
off the mark this gets
really quickly and so we talk about you
know all the different pieces of data
that we need to collect to solve
problems like this we can use
thousands of of we call them match
points thousands of ways
you think you're going to go on a list
and find triple a limousine good luck
right so
and if you think you're going to go on a
list and find triple a limousine in
china when it's not called triple a
limousine lots of luck because they
don't even have
the letter a so these are nasty problems
and one of the ways that we've
traditionally solved it is by collecting
lots and lots and lots of data
and then being really good at curating
that data into this sort of master view
of an organization and then no matter
how you ask about it
we're pretty good at getting that right
so whether you use a trade style or not
you know just doing business as
name whether you kind of spell it wrong
you know done in blade street you put
done with two ends
yeah we'll get there we'll figure it out
we look at sound we look at meaning we
look at
geospatial inference we look at
heuristics you know watching people and
what they do
we look at the context of your question
we look at transliteration and
translation we do
all of that in order to decide whether
or not
we feel as good about the answer that
we're coming up with as you do about the
question you asked
and that's just to start the process and
then of course as you get involved in
other
languages and other writing systems and
does anybody here speak a language that
anybody here speak chinese or japanese
which one chinese mandarin or
canton perfect so could you tell me what
jung ying on this
china bank not bank of china which is it
make up your mind
it doesn't matter because chinese is
palindromic right word order is
irrelevant right
so i could do zhang
no no of course not so some of the
things have to stick together but some
of the things can move right
and if i look up those let those four
characters it's
china bank in the dictionary right no
it's central kingdom silver storage
right
yeah but it's obvious right yeah so
thank you yeah okay
welcome to hell um this is another
problem and we didn't even get to the
problem yet right this is the stuff that
we do in our human brain and we just
take it for granted
and then we got to connect all of these
entities into corporate family trees
so the parent the subsidiary the branch
how hard could that be well that could
be really hard
so you go into dunkin donuts and you
trip on the carpet and you spill
something on yourself and of course it's
their fault and you want to sue them
well you need to sue dunkin donuts right
well they probably have deeper pockets
but dunkin donuts is a franchise
and the the mat that you tripped over
was in a shopping mall and the shopping
mall is owned by a management company
and the franchise is owned by a real
estate company
you gonna figure that out by looking at
the mat while you're lying there
no right so this is a problem so gravity
is not just a good idea it's the law
but trying to figure out corporate
relationships like this is
massively complicated and then trying to
do that on top of language and on top of
trade style
and we didn't even get to the problem
yet
so if we look at this total risk total
opportunity thing that's going on
where our customers come to us and ask
these questions that problem has become
much more complex
just because of the amount of noise in
the room right now so data is growing at
an unprecedented rate
the rate of growth of data is growing at
an unprecedented rate and arguably an
unmeasurable rate
and so it's kind of like jumping out the
window and as you're falling the
acceleration due to gravity is
increasing so not only are you falling
faster and faster the rate at which
you're falling faster is getting faster
that's not a good thing when we look at
the human race and our ability to
respond to that kind of growth
we're talking about things like the
black plague and ebola you know we're
not so good at those yet
i'm hoping that we're getting it better
with ebola there's some people in the
room that would be able to tell me about
that but
um so maybe i should be careful um but
my point is that
we're in uncharted waters here so at dmb
the way it plays out to me in my world
is
don't worry about the numbers here
because it's very hard to peg any of
these numbers
how many transactions a day do we do
well that depends on what you call a
transaction
how many rows of information do you do
you have well in which database there's
hundreds
well uh you know how many uh sources of
of social data do you have well it
depends on what you call a source and it
depends on what you call social
so when we try to peg this r version of
this cube
you know we can argue those of us that
are in the room from d b can argue about
almost any number here
but my point is you know people want to
know this stuff right they want to know
well how big is your data
well it's kind of like saying well you
know
how how alive is swimming
it's we're not even comparing concepts
that make any sense
and yet we need to know so this total
risk total opportunity equation has
become much more complex
we look at different different layers of
opportunity
where we used to say you know they're
likely to pay their bills or they're not
likely to pay their bills
now it turns out that people that
consistently pay their bills late could
be actually a really good credit risk
because you can charge them more money
whoops that sounds like an opportunity
right
when we start to look at segmentation
you know as a company about to grow
well if i can just look at that company
and their numbers their sales and their
employees which was our traditional way
of looking at it i might be able to
predict something
but if i could look at their customers
and their vendors and their customers
vendors and their vendors customers
vendors and their customers vendors
vendors customers and do the kevin bacon
thing
do you think i could do a better job of
figuring out when they're reaching some
change in that second derivative or
their point of inflection
i think we could and in fact we can so
some really exciting things going on in
this space but i haven't even gotten to
the problem yet
so in general the v's of big data volume
velocity variety value all those things
we got to deal with them everybody in
this room has to deal with those
but those are table stakes there's also
changes in the environment because the
the businesses in that environment know
this so for example virtual businesses
it's a lot easier now to start a
business
than it ever was if any two of us wanted
to become a consulting firm you want to
want to be consultants together
okay good are we a business yet no
sorry what do you want to call it
it's called a synergy that's a good name
okay we're gonna be synergy
inc okay are we a business yet no right
if we go on godaddy and register a
website are we a business yet
put on your credit card your mind okay
are we a business yet no we're just it's
a guy that bought a website right a web
domain
you know what i mean a domain right um
if
would you like to do business with us
totally okay
would you enter into a virtual agreement
a verbal agreement with us that in
exchange for
valuable compensation uh valuable
consideration you will compensate us at
a value that we will determine in the
next
20 minutes any lawyers in the room
we're close we're not quite a business
yet but we're getting there right can we
shake hands
can can you can you give me a dollar
because that then there's consideration
my point is
somewhere in here we're going to become
a business
but trying to find that moment in time
is is
nasty it's massively difficult and with
virtual businesses where these things
can break and
you just said i'll help you do it and i
said well what if we do some kind of a
jv and you get a share that whatnot now
are we a business
and what's a business and you know
globalization
everything's connected to everything so
we can make mistakes much faster now and
we can make much more pervasive mistakes
than we ever could
and privacy and permissible use are
changing faster than you can say privacy
and permissible use
anybody here from germany in germany
you know we could argue that if you get
on the phone and you're in germany and
i'm here and you tell me the name of
your business that you may have violated
the law
not really but it's close right there's
all kinds of strange
privacy laws there right uh we got to be
really really careful
um not that they're wrong or right they
just are china
same thing you know different set of
laws different set of complications
mexico malaysia
all of that we just got past the easy
part
now we get to the part where everything
that's changing everything that's kind
of old is new again
oh that number's counting backwards
that's not good so
when we define innovation at dmv
and when we think about what does it
really mean
these are some of the phrases we use new
ways of doing old things doing new
things
ways of doing new things creating simple
or unsolved problems those are all
arguable definitions of innovation what
about
new ways of cheating what about when
these guys did
this thing with home depot was that
innovation
yeah kind of was right so um
innovation isn't always for good and
innovation isn't always
good for everybody sometimes it's highly
massively sub-optimal
so we're trying to find the right kinds
of innovation
and that involves using lots of
information that we don't have a lot of
experience with
i'm going to be honest with you we
collect some corporate responsibility
data we don't have a lot of experience
with using that to predict the kinds of
things that we try to predict
social data i think everyone if to be
fair
is at some level of experimentation with
social data it's massively unstructured
i'm going to say unstructured in quotes
because i'm not sure what unstructured
means
often it means we don't understand it
yet um but you know where you got it you
know what it isn't
right so it's not completely
unstructured connections which we're
going to talk about today these are all
different types of information
that are on the stage now literally and
figuratively that we have to think about
how we're going to use and then we've
got signals
a lot of talk about signals this morning
and precision and recall and yeah
really really important in this space
and and proxies you know you can't get
the information you want
completely but you have enough of it to
understand how it behaves
so if i can get other information that's
equally predictive for the same
kind of decision as the data that i
don't have can i use yeah you bet you
can
as long as you do it right and you get
your chaos and your genie and all that
you got to get all that stuff right but
yes you can do it
and what about behaviors what about meta
rules rules that imply
the emergence of new rules that we don't
know about yet and and
just kind of like this conversation
what's a rule anyway
um something we call black cats uh
where's my friend sammer
i'm quoting him actually the black cat
in the dark room right so
you know is it there or is it not there
and i know you're quoting schrodinger
but
the idea being that you know we're
trying to find by the absence of the
data that we
observe the likely existence of data
that we didn't get to yet
really really powerful powerful stuff if
we can figure out how to do it right
we've got some capabilities that we've
been emerging
over the years we've been talking about
this concept of people in the in the
context of business
so we start to collect information
you're not your name right but there's a
whole bunch of data about you including
your name
and if we can start to coalesce that
information and do dynamic clustering we
can figure out
when the preponderance of information
seems to indicate the identity of a
person
eventually we get enough of that data to
say this is a collection of data about a
person and this is data that's not about
that person
and we get to this unique identity but
then we have
something that we call uh right now we
call them hyper clusters
hypercluster we used to call these
flocks because they're like flocks of
birds they're bunched they're clusters
of data that are all the same like
consultants at ibm named john smith
it gave rise to the unfortunate term
cluster flocking so
we we now call them hyper clusters but
in any event we
we have these terms for things that
didn't exist before and now we have to
measure their behavior
and then we can look at how can we use
things like that for maybe for
segmentation
or for discovery of new behaviors we're
looking at signals like
did people inquire did we see web
traffic
looking at labor market data import
export data all of this is
fodder for for the for the cannon here
and then we got this massive amount of
data that we call social
that we're really honestly i think as a
human race just beginning to figure out
how to exploit even though we've spent a
lot of money building it
the really tricky part is to pick the
pieces of it that you're going to think
about
and think about them really really
really hard and so we're in the process
of doing that right now
starting with unstructured data and
leading to the parts of social data that
we really want to pay attention to
and what kind of meaning can we get from
that sentiment signals all the things
that i've been talking about
it's a little bit like jaws we've
figured out right now that we're going
to need a bigger boat
this is much harder than anybody thinks
it is anybody that tells you it's easy
and starts with first
take all your data and put it here and
then train it well okay but
those two steps were impossible so
you know in some cases it's possible but
not for the kind of things that we're
doing so
this is a massive massively complex
problem that we're
undertaking some
things that we have to believe we have
to be able to solve things like fbi
uh hunting san francisco man with
explosives
i'm pretty sure they're not going around
blowing things up no he's not there
you know it's just bad grammar right
blind bishop appointed to c
um here's one in french
nouven photos i wonder what kind of
photo
um here are all the different spellings
of gaddafi
right we got to be able to solve
problems like that because when you
write in arabic you leave the vowels out
and then when you translate it into
english or the roman alphabet you have
to put them back
in that's why sometimes it's spelled
with a g and sometimes with a q and
sometimes with a k because it depends on
how you interpret the pronunciation of
the vowels that come after the
initial consonant which is an arabic
letter and not a roman
letter to begin with kill me now
then we have things like missing plane
found update malaysia airlines flight
370 and when you read it it's about all
the shake-ups going on in malaysia it
has nothing to do with the plane being
found and the plane hasn't been found
how dare you you made me read your
article oh i guess that's what headlines
are for right
um here's a photo and all the
astronomical data of the planet rexa
coraco falapetorius
which if any of you are doctor who fans
you'll know this is a completely
fictitious planet but it's got all kinds
of astronomical data here
so if your algorithm finds that one and
picks it up and puts it in a database
you're going to have some splaining to
do
right so some of the strategies that we
use to get around problems like this
recursion being able to build knowledge
by looking at multiple
places triangulation sort of informing
the truth
and adjudicating veracity assessment of
optimism and pessimism when people are
involved
and now we get to the really hard part
the really hard part
is about relationships so everything's
connected to everything
and if we can connect everything to
everything even though most of those
connections will be empty
the parts that aren't will be really
really powerful so we've already been
doing this for a while this is an
example of a fraud
i'm sorry a malfeasance ring uh that we
have discovered we can't call it fraud
because they didn't defraud us but
um you know we've been pretty good at
figuring out people that come on that
was funny
um we've been pretty good at figuring
out you know people that are doing
sneaky things for a long time
several hundred times a day people lie
to us are you shocked
probably more than several hundred times
a day um but now we're starting to look
at the relationships of people and
business because if we can
define what a person is in their
footprint of data
and if we can adjudicate that in a
consistent way and we can put them in
the context of a business
and we can tell when that business is
talking about itself like in a press
release
or when that person that works for that
business is talking about their business
or vice versa
or when some other business is talking
about that business or somebody who
doesn't work for that business is
talking about the person
if we can start to do all this then we
can start to look at some of these
really well guess what we can i'm not
saying we solved all the problems yet
there's still
that nasty problem of the way we use
language but being able to figure out
who's speaking and about whom and what
did they say and how did they feel when
they said it really really powerful
stuff
so these are the problems that we're
working on really really hard right now
here's an example xyz is an excellent
company to do business with
show of hands positive negative
somewhere in between
positive statement yep come on play the
game right
okay uh it's not done so we got xyz
is we can find the verb is it's
transitive verb we got the subject xyz
company xyz is company what kind of
company excellent company that's why you
said this
but the sentence isn't over so it says
if you like and if you like is in a
database of qualifiers like more or less
so to speak for the most part
so we'll take one away because we saw
that qualifier
oh the sentence isn't over yet if you
like destroying nature
right so it's sarcasm this is something
that's really hard to teach
because it's something that evolves with
language
but assuming we can wave that problem
away and if we've got this people in the
context of business thing right
we can start to look at people that are
tweeting things
and the company that they're connected
to and start to ask questions like well
if the leader of this company feels this
way
how do other people in the company feel
and is that consistent is the leader
ahead of the mean is the leader leading
the mean
is the standard deviation higher or
lower and that would imply
different things about what's going on
in terms of the intervention of that
later gee that sounds pretty powerful
and then if i could look at something
like this comment which you may have
trouble reading but it says martin
guitar makes a great instrument
martin guitar is either a person named
martin guitar or it's a company named
martin guitar but either way it's not
the company we're talking about so i
don't care
so being able to rule things out without
actually knowing what they mean
and then being able to rule out people
that have the same name that aren't the
same person
we're very very close to being able to
do this kind of stuff we can do some of
this right now
some of it is not as good enough as we
need it to be to be able to
do it for anybody else yet but if we can
draw a string around different
social sources or different unstructured
sources and then start to do the normal
measures of central tendency that you
might do and look at what's happening to
simple things like mean standard
deviation we don't to get crazy with the
math here
we can start to do some pretty powerful
things with these observed relationships
and that's just talking about the
entities now we start to talk about how
we can connect all that entity data to
other data like customer data and macro
data and signals and events
and we start to get into these dyadic
relationships
and then those dyadic relationships over
time give you longitudinal dyads and
those longitudinal dyads
projected one way or the other and what
if scenarios give you a dynamic probable
longitudinal
dyads this is the work that we're doing
with wolfram solutions right now
so how am i doing so far summer okay
so you may have missed this news article
in the data
science intelligentsia which i made up
but it's about the work
that we're doing someday we'll actually
see a real news article like that
but this is some output from some of the
cdfs that we've created with the project
that we're working on
where we've connected essentially
everything we know to everything else we
know
and this is anonymized right now and
summarized so you can't figure it out
but these are two big companies
and you can see that they're they can
see each other
and they're working with some of the
same vendors and they're very large
companies these are oil companies
um but what you may not realize
is that these guys are very dependent on
these guys and these guys are very
dependent on these guys but
we would think that that's kind of
discoverable pretty easily
what they can't see is if this guy over
here gets the flu
this guy is in trouble which puts them
both in trouble that's really
really really really hard to see because
you're talking about trillions and
trillions of diatic relationships that
need to be curated to solve a problem
like that
so kevin bacon was right relationships
do matter i'm getting the
acts so i'm going to take this really
quickly these are some
snapshots of a network view of the same
information
and then we can look at it over time
it's really cool in the tool because we
can play movies
and see how the information is changed
see it changing well it did change trust
me
so we can watch it change over time
and we can look at it spatially so
here it is projected on the us map and
then on the us map over time
so you can start to see some pretty
powerful things and then
we can look we can quantify
through through metrics that we've we've
derived that we've borrowed from biology
and chaos theory
different ways of looking at like things
like anisotropism and and homogeneity
and all those different aspects of the
data
we can drop new data on it that's drag
and dropping or drag and dropping
um and then you know finally looking at
it the stability over time to answer
some real customer questions some real
real valuable things that we can provide
to our customers so i'm done now this is
the final advice that i leave you with
which is
we do need to understand what we believe
we've got to allow data science to come
into the room we've got to be empirical
we've got to do reproducible things not
just
emotional things with the data we've got
to make new mistakes
we've got to consider a language of
inclusion you know the first 30 minutes
nobody can talk about why it won't work
just talk about all the reasons why it
can work and then allow new skills and
new science into the room because this
is all
uncharted orders for everybody we've
been using this quote from einstein for
a long time now that we can't solve
problems by using the same kind of
thinking that we used when we created
them
but i've added a new einstein quote to
our
mindset which is that everything should
be made as simple as possible but no
simpler
so thank you very much for your
attention this is great